so how different do you think your life
would be if they fixed your ears at like
fourth grade I think I'd be a total wuss
dude you think so I'd be even more of a
wuss than I am now 100% no thick skin
yeah like I developed a lot thicker skin
and I learned how to just not take
things so seriously it took a while but
I'm glad I did I did it that way cuz
when they're kids and you're teaching
them to fix their their uh issues and
you're now you're telling your kid you
are an issue honestly that's a good
point but if the kid wants lip filler
give him lip filler
they know what they want they know what
you don't want you don't want your folds
here okay excuse me you want your brows
here you want it to be smooth I feel
attack e me too